welcome to this video playing a 15
minute game against Jima from Denmark
it's assam i have played him before with
a drawl so uh huh need to be good out
here 350 points below me still i drew me
okay let's play a sideline of sloth 303
quincy to those moves are always an
option to consider if you want out of
complete mainstream theory and that that
had some interesting
yeah I don't want to take of course this
could help like I rather want him to
take one be three the this line in fact
has been played by kamsky a number of
times interestingly enough some probably
better than its reputation the screen be
sick smooth this could also arise from a
different move on if I don't play for
queen bee three but Knight c3 and then
queen bee six this has been played
perkowski as well early queen bee six
move it's sort of anticipates hmm yeah
and am I not just winning on d5 now no
I'm not okay okay i was thinking cd5 cd5
CD 595 wins upon okay cd5 queen bee
three a b3 cd59 be five wins at least
the a pond but he can take with the
night and then I don't really have have
something great hmm interesting so what
should i do foreplay foreplay Bishop f4
the general a desirable move what if it
takes on c4 Queen takes Queen B 2 it's
very cheeky very cheeky to to take this
kind of a ball but yeah maybe I can also
think about c5 but he's got Quincy 7 I
don't
like that really
yeah the sugar for he might just take on
c4 Queen takes Queen B to I don't I
totally if I'm not really sure what kind
of compensation that might be rock be
one even Quincy to is not term not
losing straight away okay if I just
briefly turn to cd5 cd5 queen bee three
a B 395
yeah that's very very little I mean he's
got the bad night on this Evan this is
some something but it's definitely not
enough to do to do to do much with but
Bishop f4 he just takes what's my move
III or something like that is really
passive maybe Bishop f4 ABA takes on c4
and Quincy to try to get it back with
you for Bishop c4 maybe okay let's let's
do that i mean probably i'm thinking all
this and not at any place quickly g6 or
some other move that does not really
address the main points but not sure
we place any other move i'm going to
place c5 basically like e6 or g 6 i'm
going to place you 5
I think you must take on c4 this is at
least the only the only continuation
that connects to the moose before yeah
okay here we go I actually should have
thought briefly about cd5 and this was
stupid what c5 is not bad for me but I
should have considered the alternative
okay let's think briefly here what about
he just went back the ideas p 6 okay I
need I need to address the b6 idea and I
need to be I need to be a lot about 85
Queen a phone yeah I'm not sure about
this move but don't want to fall behind
on the clock even more the idea is that
b6 just gives the white c6 okay I'm
going to go h3 and III to make sure i
have e 5 covered
you can try to you can try to prepare
that rupee 89 h 5v five something like
that
yeah this looks like a decent plan there
are similar position this is positions
in the chabanenko sloth sometimes like
even can play something like right back
yeah like that and then go for a quickie
five with f6 even but I don't want to
want to think too long him f65 it's not
nothing to nothing to him to be afraid
of yeah again hmm okay I'd yes but why
is this vice is not losing a porn yeah I
thought about this briefly but he I
don't see him getting the porn back
maybe Queen g5 but I've got Queen a for
quincy to Bishop e3 trapping the Queen
and I just keep the pawns now all night
c 76 is this is this the real point
maybe
maybe
well night see Sofia can play before I
mean my it's got a five
let's let's think about this for a
moment that's really a really essential
now to play to play it correctly exactly
now there's also a form in this specific
position will form
efore takes
if I go Queen D for his keys got 97 it's
not clear how I how I keep this how I
keep the pawn and if I don't keep the
pawn it does not make much sense 97b for
it's got a 5 and this is a bit bit bit
of a problem okay yeah this is not a bad
move I think it must take now Queenie 5c
ed5 is just good for white the pawn is
weak on d5 he must take now ah and then
Queen d4 that's that's the point okay
okay yeah this is strong actually even
does this is even strong but if it takes
a black Queen before I protect both
pawns and then 94 as the next move if he
goes Bishop f5 I can't even play g4 it's
no problem queen d 4 nights is 795
that's wrong yeah so if i was right i
didn't i didn't release spot it before i
played it I was before that I was
thinking okay takes and even Queen takes
should be something Quincy five and Jen
just continue I mean I have the e4 e5
pawn of Queen a 494 but takes Queen D
forces in stronger it keeps the pawn and
end the positional advantage yeah 24
that's really strong after I believe
hmm oster Bishop f5 Bishop 5g for Luke
t8 Queen III Bishop back to see 894 thus
Queenie five Queenie for the screen c5
not sure yeah still still not not bad at
all there should have five it's there an
alternative after that Bishop f5 g4 is
completely normal looking maybe rock d1
just roped you one yeah work T 1 maybe
31 OOP Tian Wow and this I didn't didn't
consider at all which does not mean it
is bad I mean I just didn't think about
it Wow
yeah it keeps the pawn it keeps the pawn
amazing
I was calculating some nice lines but I
didn't think about that at all it keeps
the pawn for heaven's sake and that
makes it a much stronger more than what
I thought was once i'm going to be
played yeah okay i'm falling behind on
the clock better items quicker if i give
this check bishop is six Queenie five
look the 8th yeah that's not really
helpful
put it put it only useful useful file I
don't what I'm not sure about it should
I castle this is the type of endgame
there my king I mean it's not the end
game yet but if we get to an end game
III would be a nice square for my king
attacking you see for porn this is why
I'm not castling yet I probably need to
do that but you never know
yeah twenty-six cents maybe even Queen
f7
then what happens if i just take e form
94 I don't just see it at the moment see
just taking on a true words so yeah
maybe looks a bit weird but maybe now
now it's how to how to play without
castles look the eight queen III night x
I think you really could take a two but
now I'm threatening to take maybe after
luke t 8 mm hm queen e5 was my idea but
97 seems ok maybe 97 Quincy seven now
that's that's that's interesting
maybe that's interesting so rook the
eighth Queenie five keeping the pressure
on the e4 pawn
yeah it's not okay
so just green these six to exchange
Queens yeah why you see will play rock
the aid I mean where is my queen going
okay let's get the Queen self yeah you
can I think he can basically choose
between wookie age and taking if it
takes I'm taking with the rook of course
checking with the point is just a
weakness on the 60 takes yes this was
also possible of course and what now how
exactly do I proceed yeah maybe that's a
three in the mix
okay let's let's take and now what now
maybe rookies so I am something like
that III I can take f6 hang so and this
prepares the doubling and keep some
pressure on your form
hmm yeah I'm not sure him should I get
the night to III from C 3 23 he may be
can just prepare III and get rid of this
pawn yeah this is at best at best a very
slight edge to what probably it's just
nothing yeah III the question is after
move like III I can I can even think
about them moving the f-bomb maybe rock
t6 that's 95 so III is a move like f4
insane playing for a loss maybe it is
part very hard to play I go 91 with the
intention s this myth is 93 idea he
might play a 95 Bishop a tool that's ok
for ok still I'm not risking much I
don't think I risked much 95 I have
various moves I mean the e3 idea let's
say + 95 I play something he plays III
we just exchange stuff it's not like I
was 95 mm this should push up a two yr
okay for I mean does this smile maybe
something like take a 71 next move
something does not mean like something
great but maybe some way to continue
yeah I missed f5 this was really a good
defensive move after that maybe maybe
White has something but I didn't find it
yeah and he's playing well yeah Bishop
c4 was was an idea but he's got at least
nine f4 we got if he'd be raised III Jim
okay let's put it here if you place
night therefore I just I just I just
cover it now wait if I cover it you
might take here but okay I always have
okay 47 yeah mmhmm yeah I'm trying to to
play for something here maybe I
shouldn't
yeah not not clear if Bishop c4 is
helping me takes rook takes it just has
rocked the eight or something it's not I
really don't have any any kind of
advantage two minutes 11 now that's not
comfortable look the eight I probably I
probably go look the one or up t7 get
get one pair of rooks off so that at the
end he needs to watch out for the e4
pawn yeah at least this is a slight
weakness it's not like it's nothing but
he's got this active night yeah this is
important that i also have king f1 maybe
you can go 93 him just stay active check
you
rakta for has a funny movie takes 92 but
at the end I've ever by the end game so
it's not nothing to fear night end game
is slightly better for me okay at least
now you cannot move the node because of
the e4 pawn I should pleasure the ticket
shut the ticket 91 91 c 3
nice quickie
attending 96 move 124
now a tricky position he can give give
this checks here check HERE kingly to
check again i hope i can just advance
and then take the palm but he's got rock
before at the end maybe I'd I have 96 96
I don't i don't know i need to do that
b7 Hank c4 hangs d 4 eggs isn't this
good now can take him
yeah look behave
she just not threatened to take here can
see 597 I'm a BSB 6cm be 6mm try to take
a 6 ok well it's with the check
unbelievable move Wow check
okay some of the worst is over I'm still
in slide trouble time with freedom check
check check check check check draw
Alfred Jim yeah well i was i was even
lost at one point the rook endgame here
nite nite b5 was exceptionally strong
around here I think I I have relatively
clear edge but I don't I didn't play it
precisely 93 a spare tire from ya around
here I really should win the game I mean
this this this is somewhat this is a
week but it's not not easy Nyjah for
seems to be good with Knight f6 now this
this is a nice one now he's got the
problem rook t7s 95 quite interesting
and if he goes here yeah yeah yeah this
is I had the hunch that there's some
overloading theme going on but I didn't
didn't play it precisely i played this
one first
and now it's it's that's not that's not
clear yeah that's very strong I mean it
PDF play very strong here I cannot take
hero create I mean this is even leading
to problems I went here and I'll be five
or strong which he didn't see here only
he saw that and now yeah yeah before him
I was thought I can always get the rook
back here but he's got night f5 on I'd
be five and they're both strong that's
very strong yeah yeah it's it's I was
evident he always playing for win here
and it's not just a fight in this
position anymore yeah here I'm just I'm
just lost in the end game he can't he
just needs to play rook t5 here and I'm
almost resigning I'm TM this is a go k
again probably drama sh but you can
never really win it and slight I mean I
I managed the the almost best possible
outcome by winning the two pawns yeah
but it's this is just that this is
positioned game nothing to do oh yeah
tough game I didn't I didn't consider a
five at all it's clearly the best move
so maybe we have a 24 was good yo I mean
white is somewhat better here but it's
not it's not too spectacular yeah this
is probably not not the right idea
yeah but it's it's very difficult i mean
is he's got III coming I thought briefly
about something like that trying to play
for one in this fashion but this is
really weak I don't know and I don't
think so really this can easily be a be
a losing attempt yeah not really great
yeah this is also the type of game that
that shows why it is not so easy to get
to get something going in this rating
you play like 10 players and row that
are clearly weaker rating wise and you
score like a now nine out of 10 and you
don't win points and it happens they
they sometimes just defend to defend
well I mean you played a good game here
after he misplayed the opening here that
really was good I mean it's just like
just amazing but it uh maybe you can do
that I mean yes f5 which I didn't really
appreciate and this leads to to a decent
position so it's quite strange the weird
thing about this is that I I probably
must take I mean if I don't take the e
poor might get weak and the capture is
the least move I mean you don't really
want to take because it it gets the
night into play immediately it was on
this terrible yet square but no
alternative interesting game really
thanks for watching